the DC movie lineup over the next couple
years is mucho exciting and that
includes Wonder Woman 1984 which has
some new casting details so let's
discuss everything we already know about
the movie right now on the ketchup
Wonder Woman 1984 will release on June
5th 2020 following the February 7th drop
of DC's birds of prey and the
fantabulous emancipation of one harley
quinn by the way if you haven't already
checked out our episode on that film go
over there for more info the trailer for
Wonder Woman 1984 will debut at a
Brazilian convention called CC XP in
early December so get ready to hear that
epic Wonder Woman theme song very soon
unless you switch it up and go with an
80s version the two big reasons we love
2017 certified fresh hit Wonder Woman so
much are coming back and that is gal
gadot as Wonder Woman herself and patty
Jenkins as director and co-writer Warner
Media recently through an HBO max
presentation for the new streaming
service that's coming out next year and
for good measure debuted some new 1984
footage to the room it included Wonder
Woman battling enemies inside the White
House and a possible dream sequence of
Diana and Steve Trevor walking in front
of the Washington Monument so Washington
DC seems to be a major location
hashtag Wonder Woman for president as
far as the story goes we know that the
adventures for Diana will be set in the
1980s during the Cold War with some
speculation that she'll be working under
the radar as some sort of spy behavior
it was confirmed recently after a fun
Twitter exchange with Jenkins and actor
Pedro Pascal that is once mysterious
casting is now officially Maxwell Lord
in the comics Lord once finance of
Justice League International before
outing himself as a telepathic super
villain and villain or antihero seems to
be Pedro's thing these days because he's
also the lead in the new Star Wars
series the Mandalorian check out our
episode about that if you haven't
already but it's nice because in this
movie we'll actually get to see his face
yeah Pascal will join Kristen Wiig who
is playing the villain cheetah a
character that in the comics is driven
by her jealousy Wonder Woman
I can't really blame her but also still
trying to process the fact that target
lady is now a DC villain
some stars that are returning for the
sequel include Connie Nielsen as Queen
Hippolyta and Robin Rhea as general
auntie AVI and some teaser images
revealed in May that Chris Pine is back
playing Steve Trevor
despite the character having died in the
climax of the first movie spoiler alert
but patty Jenkins has said in interviews
that Pines appearance will totally make
sense and many think that the
mind-control abilities of Maxwell Lord
may have something to do with it that or
he got a hold of back to the features
DeLorean I mean this does take place in
the 80s right it has to be me as far as
how this film fits into the DC EU given
that during this time period Batman was
just a boy mourning his parents death
and Superman had just crashed landed in
Smallville
Wonder Woman may be doing her thing a
little more under wraps as him around
and with the recent shift in focus to
standalone director driven films like
Joker the gold Wonder Woman 1984 is
likely to add to Diana's backstory and
her progression as a superhero and patty
Jenkins has said she has plans for a
potential third Wonder Woman movie this
one would apparently take place in the
present and wrap up Diana's character
arc so if anything that could be a film
that plays a bigger role in the
continuity of the DC EUI no total nerd
alert but now you know it's about what
you believe
and I believe in that I want to kick it
over to you now are you excited for
Wonder Woman 1984 if so what are you
hoping we learn about her in this movie
and are you stoked it takes place in the
80s I am let us know in the comments
section and for more DC news head on
over to Rotten Tomatoes calm and good
news our first book ride movies we love
is out right now celebrates 101 movies
that are coming in green but definitely
worth checking out and makes a great
gift for your friends that love Ryan
movies as always thanks for watching the
ketchup and if you like this episode and
you want to see more subscribe and click
that Bell icon I'm not for us and I'll
see you guys next time
[Music]